[Music]
I've been thinking about this a lot
lately uh we eat uh animals of course uh
in this country big animal eaten
country I've been thinking about this
though you know we eat some animals in
this country but we don't eat other
animals you ever think about that like
we eat pig of course but we don't eat
dog but did you know that pigs are like
much smarter than dogs but we eat them
we just we don't care we just eat the
pink Genius of the farm
why I've been thinking about it why I
think I figured it out I think it's
Hooves that's right
Hooves the evil
feet picture a dog with
Hooves now picture everyone applauding
as I drop KCK that monster onto a lit
Grill you would eat that demon dog that
dog if you have hooves in this country
yeah get political in this
country if you have hooves you're either
the devil or
breakfast either way I'm coming at you I
don't feel judged I'm just saying we eat
animals because we don't give a
that's really what it is I feel you back
away like I care you don't care don't
act like you care I care about chickens
how many chickens you eat today a
million was it a million we don't give a
cuz they're dumb dumb chickens bar
bar baking all goddamn day who gives a
I feel you being like I care you
don't care let a kid kill one with
safety scissors let him learn how the
world
works but you ever go to dinner and
someone's like is this chicken free
range usually me is this free range who
cares what's he going to do outside
stare at the sun it's
stupid if chickens were smart if a
chicken was like hello with
a if a chicken was like I've been
reading Ulisses you're not you're not
going to deep fry that one you're going
to go on a road trip with that chicken
put him in a child's seat go to Montana
vineet hit Vine 2013 road trip
chicken it's
weird
sure maybe it should be done but I'm not
done that felt like a conclusive he's
made his
point cow
[Applause]
H cows dumb shits
too I'm just saying all they do is mosy
how much moseying can you do and still
be respected as a species you understand
eating grass digesting it with your
weird sick stomachs nobody cares num
here's the thing though you can't be
mean to a cow like I couldn't punch a
cow if it was like me and you in a field
it's just you and me and the cow I don't
know how we got
there but if I was like check this out
I'm going punch the cow and then and
you're like
no and I punch him not even in the face
that's too obvious I punch him in the
side there's that dull Hollow thud why
do we all know exactly what it would
sound like you're picturing it perfectly
just that in the cow's
like I'm a sociopath right that's a
friendship Ender you'd stop hanging out
with me but if I know Country For Old
menet if I'm just like don't put it in
your pocket and then I just in the cow's
like oh dead everyone's like
[Music]
barbecue what the doesn't add up but the
reason is we think we're so much smarter
we humans think we're so much smarter
than animals so we deserve to eat the
dummies but here's the thing I worry
what if we're not the smartest thing in
the universe what if aliens come what if
aliens come and they're smarter than us
and they think we're delicious
I can feel you not worrying about
this but I think about it cuz we're not
worried or like oh aliens land we' be
like
welcome we're just like you we're smart
we made Capri
son uh we made the
monal look it's the
iPad but they don't care they probably
been watching us for Millennia above
from above and what are we doing that's
so great just shuffling around shopping
malls no one even looks at each other
just live tweeting your experience as
you wait in line at a Spencer's gifts
for an apron that looks like you're
naked you know what that looks like from
[Applause]
[Music]
above